[Music]
if you're anything like me chances are
high that whether you're watching a
movie or watching live TV or maybe doing
a Netflix marathon at some point during
your watching going to pick up either a
tablet or your phone and you're going to
look up some information that's related
to what you're watching this is the
concept of second screen users now 42%
of second screen users have accessed
synchronized program content during live
TV so maybe they're going off to look up
a contest that was mentioned or maybe
they're looking up to see who an actor
or an actress is you know cuz I know
I've seen them in something before or
maybe they saw a TV commercial or they
saw a product mention and they're
looking for more information on it now
interestingly 41% of synchronized
content users are parents to kids under
18 that's the highest of all the
demographics so these are groups that
are looking a lot of times to see what
their teens are watching or looking up
additional information you know based on
what their younger kids might be asking
about now 75% of synchronized content
users say synchronized content on a
second screen makes TV more enjoyable 33
percent of Millennials use Twitter
primarily for their second screen
content so again we see a lot of
Millennials even more so than any other
age group that are using Twitter at the
same time that they're watching TV
because they've got running commentary
going along with it now second screen
usage is common and it's becoming more
and more common when we look at the
breakdown for a study that was done at
the end of 2013 we see that
interestingly well we see a lot of
second screen usage among those
smartphone owners and tablet owners
there's a couple key areas where there's
some big differences in terms of who's
doing what now it should come as no
surprise that you can have more tablet
owners surfing the web than smartphone
owners because clearly most smartphone
owners are going to use it for things
more like you know texting a friend or
making phone calls but when we look at
data like shopped online and we see that
tablet owners are almost twice as likely
to be shopping online
smartphone owner this comes back to that
idea of the granular level device
targeting that we know we can do on
Twitter and that there can be a big
difference in the paired content that
you send out as part of your TV
targeting to those on a tablet versus
those on a smartphone because of the
difference in buta likelihood of
following through
same thing with looking up program
related information far more likely to
happen with tablet owners whereas things
like sports stores tends to be pretty
close to even and of course texting
friends no big surprise is going to lean
more into the smartphone owners category
but when we get down into some of the
other areas you know follow program
related social media activity again
still pretty similar but then pop down
to bought a product advertised on TV and
we see that once again tablet owners
crush smartphone owners in this category
which again makes it that much more
necessary to have really great targeted
campaigns that are specifically going
after the call to actions by when you're
targeting those tablet owners now
Nielsen has partnered with Twitter
within the last year or so to start
putting out what they call the Nielsen
Twitter TV ratings and what they're
doing now is they're looking at a
combination of things they're looking at
the number of tweets that are coming out
of around any particular TV show they're
looking at the number of people that are
doing that tweeting and then they're
also looking at the reach of that
conversation so the number of people who
are seeing those tweets coming out and
what we see happening is far more
conversations about shows like breaking
bad as opposed to NCIS we find that the
demographics that are showing up for the
Twitter eyes TV shows you know tend to
be those millennial groups that are
turning to Twitter in order to talk
about shows like breaking bad or Game of
Thrones as opposed to the NCIS crowd
that tends to be maybe a little older or
maybe a little bit less likely to be on
Twitter and we don't see as much of an
overlap in fact when we look at the top
shows as represented by Twitter versus
the top shows on regular TV listings we
see a pretty big difference the ones on
the Left are actually the top Twitter
ratings and the ones on the right are
the top standardized television ratings
there's almost no overlap
the two between the most tweeted and the
most watched programs about the only
exception are the voice for the
particular week that this was taken now
again it's important to remember that
Twitter represents only a portion of the
broader population and it tends to
represent a very specific targeted
portion of the population so it's very
important as you're getting ready to do
any TV based advertising to make sure
you're looking at the true demographics
of who's watching particular shows and
then to go to Twitter and spend some
time doing some of the research there to
see your people actually talking about
it as well because it's not going to be
in your best interest to try and push
you know your co-branded content for a
commercial that you're running on NCIS
as it would be for what you might be
running on Breaking Bad or you know
Grey's Anatomy so again there's going to
be some difference with very very little
overlap here and it's very important to
keep that in mind whether you're a huge
company or a small company there's still
strong potential here because again when
we look at those key demographics that
have really strong presence on Twitter
especially when we look at that
millennial crowd we find that there's a
lot of space because there's a lot of
overlap in the target audience so if we
think of a huge company like Taco Bell
and we compare them to a smaller company
like lebombo which is a very popular
fast casual Mexican restaurant in the
Midwest that tends to set up shop in
college towns they're both going after
college students they're both going
after that late-night post bar crowd you
know those you only live once types
these tend to be users who are highly
connected to the web they watch shows
like How I Met Your Mother and Breaking
Bad and the Big Bang Theory and Game of
Thrones again there's a lot of overlap
even though these are two very different
sized companies so taking advantage of
the TV based opportunities that Twitter
offers each of these companies can come
at their message from sort of a
different perspective to still get their
tweets in front of the right sets of
people so for our enterprise and agency
listeners it's very important to
understand that Twitter amplify
basically gives big brands the
opportunity to combine two
conversation with the TV ads that
they're already running association with
certain shows so Nielsen's brand effect
for twitter data has lots of great
information out there in terms of what
this edition of twitter advertising to
existing television advertising can mean
the incremental acquisition cost from TV
advertising decreases by about 36% if
those same ads are paired up with with
the Twitter advertising presence the
incremental sales that's going out has
an 8 to 16 percent increase when you go
from standard TV to TV plus Twitter
advertising advertisers that are running
both TV commercials and Promoted Tweets
have a 95 percent stronger message
association they have a 58 percent
higher purchase intent again popping
back up to those ones above we see 8 to
16 percent more sales and a 36 percent
lower customer acquisition cost and
these are really big differences in
overall brand spends and overall
advertising spends so what Twitter
amplified does is it runs through the
third party API ad partners and it
allows you to have an embedded video run
right there within your ad the same way
that you might embed a YouTube video the
difference is these ads are usually
partnered with whatever live TV program
someone happens to be watching in order
to offer supplemental content or maybe a
Content recap so for example ESPN
college football uses it to run football
instant replays during the game so just
like you can watch the instant replay
briefly on the screen right after it
happens they're going to tweet out that
same thing and people are going to have
instant access whenever they want during
the course of the game to go back and
look up those play highlights now the
great thing about this is you have the
opportunity for an additional inserted
add option that's either running
pre-roll or postural so now ESPN can
sell that ad space that's running before
or after that instant replay and they
can integrate that as part of their
overall TV advertising opportunities so
again on the agency side if you happen
to be
during a live show you know like The
Voice or you know like ESPN college
football you have the opportunity to
pull those little snippets of the show
have them ready to go and be released
ahead of time and have your clients add
associated with it on the pre-roll or
the post roll now the other great thing
is that you can take these amplify ads a
step further but integrating Twitter
cards in creating conversion points so
when the NBA was using amplify in order
to put out instant replays on the NBA
side of things they were selling ads
based all sorts of different places
including the Will Smith movie after
earth and you can see down there at the
bottom we actually have a conversion
point right there within the ad itself
while the videos playing saying go and
follow this movie on Twitter so again
with Twitter cards which we'll talk
about further in the last video in this
series you have a lot of opportunity to
get some of those really great literal
conversion points paired in with the ad
content that's paired in with the TV
show that you're already doing
advertising on now on the small business
side of things and again larger
companies can do this as well but for
small business targeting you have the
opportunity to come in with what's
called TV conversation targeting so
let's go back to our example of la Bamba
Mexican restaurant we have a smaller
advertiser they've got a clear TV
audience match for specific shows like
let's say ESPN's BCS Bowl preview there
in college towns getting in front of
some of those selected shows and
choosing those targeted geographical
locations saying hey we want to be in
Columbus and Indianapolis and Chicago
and Louisville Kentucky because that's
where our stores are allows them to get
those targeted messages out or even
untargeted messages if they want but to
get those targeted messages out to
remind people hey while you're watching
the game stop by and pick up one of
those burritos as big as your head or
you know here's the special that we're
running in this particular city because
they're teams playing in one of the bowl
games so the fact that you can go in and
look up some of these specific shows and
look for the people who are talking
about the specific shows and get your ad
in front of them opens the door to
companies of all sizes to at least be
able to take part in some of this
conversational targeting hey once you
become an expert in digital marketing
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn up and get certified in
digital marketing quick here